bonjour et bien la chandeleur selon la
tradition c'est la fin de l'hivernage
c'est le début du renouveau c'est la
reprise des travaux des champs en fait
c'est déjà un petit peu d'espérance de
ce soleil qui nous attend pour bientôt
de soleil qui est parfois très loin des
nouvelles que nous vous donnons des
nouvelles qui sont parfois actuellement
gain peu réjouissantes
au cours de cette édition nous vous
parlerons des négociations qui s'ouvrent
aujourd'hui à la sncf entre la direction
et les syndicats notamment sur le retour
de la semaine à 40 heures et nous avons
à ce sujet un certain nombre
d'informations très précises concernant
ces négociations qui se sont ouvertes ce
matin nous vous dirons un mot du
moyen-orient et du vietnam trois jours
avant le début de la fête du têt est
tout de suite un accident ferroviaire
qui vient de se produire en argentine
200 personnes ont été tuées et plus de
400 blessées à la suite d'une collision
de trains et qui s'est produite à 40 km
de buenos aires
c'est l'une des plus grosses
catastrophes ferroviaires de ce siècle
daniel cazals avant d'en venir au triste
bilan des accidents de la route nous
avons un chalutier qui s'est échoué
oui ce matin chez lui et s'est échoué
sur la côte atlantique près de la plage
de lacanau sur les cinq membres de
l'équipage trois sont portées disparues
les deux autres sont c'est ce week-end
pluvieux willis le bilan des accidents
de la route et malheureusement on n'aime
pas faire de sensationnel chez nous mais
il faut dire qu'un record a été battu
enfin un record disons pas exactement
parce que vous savez que en été il ya
beaucoup plus de circulation sur les
routes évidemment les bilans sont plus
élevés mais disons que ce dimanche ils
week end a été plus meurtrier que le
dimanche précédent 76 morts 608 blessés
l'accident le plus grave s'est déroulé
près de troyes il a fait six morts dont
quatre de la même famille
17 heures hier sur la nationale 60 près
de pin et dans l'aube une deux chevaux
est doublé par un véhicule qui se met
brusquement à zigzaguer alors que vient
en face une voiture roulant en direction
de trois
le choc est d'une rare violence cette
dernière voiture et traîné sur plusieurs
mètres et termine sa course sur le bas
côté de la cependant que la deux chevaux
recevait à l'avant le bloc moteur de
névé les autorités ainsi qu'une équipe
de réanimation étaient rapidement sur
les lieux et les deux voitures
irrécupérable ont retiré cicad a donné
cazals un premier résultat des
négociations qui viennent de sauver ce
matin à la sncf contre la direction du
syndicat
oui premiers résultats un résultat
concret les cheminots seront augmentés
de 1 % et cela à partir du 1er janvier
1970 une majoration identique d'ailleurs
intervenir en principe dans les autres
villes entreprises nationalisées et cela
au titre du rattrapage sur le pouvoir
d'achat 1969 pour ce qui est de la
réduction du temps de travail bien aucun
accord n'a été réalisée direction et
syndicats se retrouveront le 12 février
à l'argentière le travail a repris ce
matin à la mine de penarroya après
l'accord intervenu hier cet accord
prévoit notamment une augmentation des
salaires
l'indexation des salaires sur le coût de
la vie la réduction du temps de travail
et enfin la gratuité du logement à paris
la hausse des tarifs de la ratp
entré en vigueur hier a provoqué ce
matin quelques incidents notamment à la
gare souterraine d'austerlitz où des
manifestants ont distribué des tracts et
sur ce tract qu'on pouvait lire l'état
ne nous transporte pas une nouveau roule
vous voyez que même en étant mécontents
ils gardent le sens de l'humour et lieu
cependant quelques bousculades et la
police a dû arrêter un certain nombre de
manifestants après vérification
d'identité deux arrestations étaient
minces à nanterre une précision qu'on
avait déjà
l'autre jour oui à nanterre et bien la
faculté toujours fermée aujourd'hui d'un
réouverture interviendra demain et
demain sans quelque sorte une journée
test car les enseignants
on annonçait que si de nouveaux troubles
se produisait et bien il se lancerait
dans une grève illimitée c'est donc très
important pour les étudiants à
l'étranger je crois qu'on s'oriente
surtout vers le vietnam mais parce que
dans quelques jours dans trois jours a
commencé la fête du têt nouvel an
vietnamien du nouvel an lunaire et
d'habitudes des trêves sont respectés de
part et d'autre pensez vous que la trêve
une fois de plus va être respectée en
principe cette trêve devrait être
inspecté les deux parties se sont
engagées à la respecter mais trois jours
avant le début de cette trêve les fnl
qui le front national de libération a
lancé une vaste offensive sur le sur le
sud vietnam et c'est ainsi qu'en 24
heures 70 position américaine et sud
vietnamiennes ont été harcelés par des
mortiers par des requêtes au 6 mars dans
trois jours on pense que les armes
devraient se taire au proche orient nous
avons encore des combats cette fois ci à
la frontière israélo syrienne
oui d'un à la limite
de la zone 2 de cessez le feu cessez le
feu c'est ça merci entre israël et la
syrie il ya depuis plus de trois heures
maintenant des duels d'artillerie des
combats aériens entre les israéliens et
les syriens et de son explication alors
que donne israël oui personnel donne
deux explications d'abord la syrie veut
faire la preuve de son dynamisme
militaire et cela avant le 7 février qui
est le jour où se réunira un petit
sommet arabe au caire un sommet
réunissant les pays engagés directement
dans le conflit en fin deuxième
explication
la syrie veut opérer une diversion de
façon à réduire la pression israélienne
sur le front égyptien sur le plan
diplomatique on parle aussi du
moyen-orient on va en parler ce soir
exactement au carré à paris d'abord au
caire le président nasser parlera du
proche-orient une la situation devant
200 parlementaires de 50 pays et ce soir
également
il est probable que sera abordé ce
problème au cours de la réunion qui doit
rassembler le président georges pompidou
et le roi hassan ii du maroc le roi
hassan ii du maroc sera reçu ce soir à
l'elysée mais pour l'instant le roi
hassan ii et chez le président bourguiba
à paris car le président bourguiba est
en convalescence à paris est le roi du
maroc lui a rendu visite ce matin
l'ambassade de tunisie
je crois que l'essentiel des
conversations entre le roi hassan ii et
le président pompidou qui ont pu avoir
lieu se trouve autour de ce désir commun
de faire de la méditerranée occidentale
un point d'équilibré cela est valable
pour la france pour le maroc et pour des
pays aussi comme l'italie nous arrivons
maintenant aux sports alain billoin nous
en avons déjà parlé hier soir jean
christophe est mort suspecte une disons
peut-être la plus grande figure du
premier tour de france
oui effectivement le jeune christophe
était un personnage légendaire du tour
de france et il est mort en fin de
soirée à l'hôpital broussais il était
âgé de 85 ans l'évocation de la carrière
sportive de jeunes christophe permet de
retracer à elle seule toute une période
héroïque du tour de france dont il fut
l'un des pionniers mais nous retiendrons
surtout son haut fait d'armes dans le
col du tourmalet en 1913 et stuff casse
à la fourche de son vélo et couvrit 14
kilomètres à pied pour trouver une forge
à sainte marie de campan
il répare à lui-même son vélo et repris
la route
eugène christophe c'était une grande
figure du sport français la suite de
l'actualité sportive maintenant avec le
match de rugby
tarbes stade montois la pluie tombait
fort sur le tas de maurice trélut de
tarbes recevait le stade montois à match
à panache attendu par la foule des
supporters des deux équipes et qui
débute et al'avantage des montois ceux
ci gagnant les balles en touche longue
balle exploité par ligne d'attaqué tu te
remettre à jouer andré boniface
mais les tarbais ont une défense très
serré et colt au ballon et à la 9e
minute
c'était la contre attaque civière échoué
sur le poteau de touche et sur cette
touche laval était pour les tarbais
martinez infiltrés et marquer l'essai
essai qui n'était pas transformé terrain
trop lourd balle trop lourde aussi 3 0
pour les taper les montois continuer
sans interruption sur ces attaques et
interruption de la lan je passe de boli
c'était le deuxième était à la 31e
minute et c'est toujours non transformé
6 à 0 pour les montois c'était le score
à la mi temps
dès la deuxième mi temps les tarbais
affiché une nette assurance avec leurs
six points d'avancé leur troisième ligne
creuser des brèches et c'était une
réception de cl hier qu'elle ait marqué
un essai plein de classe sur un coup de
pied d'andré boniface 9 à 0
la 48e minute je voyais ce score
al'avantage de tarbes et mont de marsan
essayé tant bien que mal se dégager se
dégage et continuer par ces folles
attaque et la berge escaut réceptionné
parts et résolument à l'attaqué données
tamarins marin à d'argelès à l'intérieur
dargelès au centre lalanne à
l'opportuniste lalanne qui allait
marquer sous le nez de deux défenseurs
montaut c'était la 69e minute 12 à 0
pour les tarbais le dernier récit de la
rencontre allait être marquée par les
avants tarbes et sur une de leurs
combinaisons qui permettait au talonneur
d'argelès prescrire ce dernier restait à
la 80e minute 15 à 0 score lourd pour
les montois à l'issue d'une fort belle
partie un mot de boxe très rapidement
pour signaler qu'un gala se déroule ce
soir au palais des sports pour combat
vedette bouttier contre miranda en
moyens et amis contre vieira en super
légers et nous suivons maintenant une
compétition originale
il s'agit du concours mondial des
scooters de neige les premiers
championnats du monde de scooter des
neiges se sont disputés deux jours
durant dans la vallée du queyras dans
les alpes du sud
trois épreuves étaient inscrits dans
cette première rencontre mondiale une
épreuve de maniabilité une épreuve de
fond et une de vitesse l'épreuve de fond
s'est déroulé sur un tracé long de 110
km/ha a review le départ donné à château
queyras permettait aux concurrents
italiens suédois et français après un
parcours commun de 11km de pouvoir
ensuite opéré un mouvement de dispersion
ce fut une épreuve où l'endurance des
mécaniques que fut soumise à rude
pression la dextérité des pilotes
faisant le reste
un coefficient venez pondérer les temps
réalisé un classement toutes catégories
sanctionner les meilleurs chronos
le suédois bo hellberg devait être
crédité du meilleur temps
le scandinave la veille dans l'épreuve
de maniabilité avait que deux minutes de
justifier déjà sa supériorité en
devançant le français ferrari ce d'une
minute 22 secondes la troisième épreuve
la vitesse qui se disputait à ceillac
voyait les concurrents sélectionnés
prendre le départ sur un anneau de
vitesse
800 mètres de long aux bords relevés sur
ce difficile circuit des aiguilles le
représentant des guides de haute
montagne jacques s'ennuyer devait
s'imposer
irrésistiblement devant un autre
français ferrari ce le suédois bo
hellberg s'assurant une place de 4e qui
lui permettait de triompher au
classement général en une heure 56
minutes et 25 secondes devant le
français gua après le succès de
popularité d'engouement remporté par
cette nouvelle discipline des neiges
il est fortement question d'en faire à
l'avenir d'une classique annuelle l'un
des problèmes les plus délicats de la
vie moderne
c'est le rapport entre l'homme et
l'animal
pourquoi parce que dans la vie moderne
et bien on consomme on consomme de plus
en plus d'animaux sur tout sur toutes
leurs formes
on consomme dépôt parce que les tripots
de certains animaux ont fait des
manteaux et puis on consomme aussi
quotidiennement pour ceux qui ne sont
pas végétariens
on consomme aussi de la viande de
boucherie on consomme dépôts et vous
avez dû entendre parler il y a plusieurs
mois de cette hécatombe dans les pays du
grand nord sur la personne si je puis
dire des jeunes phoques et des
reportages photographiques ont eu lieu
dans de grands hebdomadaires parisien
montrant avec quelle peu d'humanité on
pouvait tuer ces jeunes enfants phoque
pour recueillir leur peau
maintenant c'est chose réglée puisque
les norvégiens et les canadiens viennent
de se mettre d'accord et il y a
interdiction totale de s'attaquer aux
jeunes phoques humaniser c'est aussi le
problème en ce qui concerne la viande
que nous consommons tous les jours à 9
oui justement mon propos dans le film
que nous allons voir tout de suite n'est
pas de rendre végétarien tous les
téléspectateurs mais c'est de rendre
compte d'un problème qui est je crois
très important et c'est celui vous
pourriez d'humanisation tout à l'heure
c'est tout à fait ça c'est tout à fait
le problème car en fait 30% des bêtes
qui sont encore abattus actuellement
sentent ne sont pas abattus dans les
conditions logiques d'un décret qui
pourtant a été voté et qui devrait
appliquer le problème justement ça te
faire adopter enfin faire appliquer ce
décret et c'est notre propos
le l'objet d'un procès celui ci va
tenter d'humaniser leur mort pour
l'instant atroce c'est bête subi la loi
de moïse
vous mangerez de tout animal qu'à la
corne fendu le pieds fourchus es-tu
rumine
il posera sa main sur la tête du vous
les gorgerat le dépouillent ira et les
couperont en morceaux
madame gilardoni vous êtes présidente et
fondatrice de l'oeuvre d'assistance aux
bêtes d'abattoirs absolument vous battez
vous sur deux plans premièrement les
décret ne sont pas appliquées
actuellement à la villette pour 30% des
bêtes
deuxièmement encore et partout où toute
la france des gens maltraite des bêtes
et il ya les prochai continuelle oui à
la ville est effectivement 30% des
animaux abattus ne sont pas conformément
aux règlements en vigueur
des veaux des bovins sont suspendus
vivant pour aller jusqu'au poste de mise
à mort les veaux sous la souffrance
d'ordre et les bovins et d'ovins 900 kg
sont suspendus ban jarret et ceci après
une chute brutale et leurs souffrances
et tina et dimanche m gauthier nous
allons voir ensemble aspects juridiques
de la question est bien au point de vue
juridique
nous avons un décret cas décret qui date
de 1964 qui est donc relativement aux
siens il a six ans actuellement
ce décret donner aux abattoirs un délai
deux d'environ trois ans pour se mettre
en règle
c'est adele est amplement suffisant
d'autant plus que le matériel exister
face aux matelles régulier existe depuis
longtemps
la plupart des abattoirs sont mises en
plis en principe toute bête doit être
rendue inconsciente avant la saignée par
divers procédés il n'y a pas que le
talent est il a été cité il ya le co2
mais certaines dérogations sont en
vigueur mais elle concerne l'abattage
rituel
c'est à dire et bien l'abattage
israélite et musulman
alors selon leur loi eh bien les animaux
doivent être égorgés en pleine
conscience mais pour la préparation
nous sommes en plein accord avec le
rabbinat et eux aussi des fleurs ce qui
se passe à la villette sur leur chaîne
nous avons obtenu du grand rabbinat de
france que les appareils de contention
application peines qui sont en fonction
en angleterre en allemagne au danemark
en fait donc pas mal du pays soit
installée à la villa et y en a trois
mais ils ont été installés telle façon
qu'ils sont inutilisables
oui si vous êtes un sujet vous avez
pensé devant être un petit peu difficile
à voir à la mi-journée comme ceux ci
mais il était tout de même important
justement parce que c'est peut-être
alors du défi jaune et de passer un tel
sujet parce que tous les jours on se
trouve en présence de ce problème
pas tellement dans les villes mais
peut-être surtout dans les provinces et
dans les campagnes où justement
l'humanisation n'est pas toujours très
respecté oui justement enfin il ya des
projets qui sont enfin régulièrement
presque tous les jours des avocats
traite ce genre de procès parce que
enfin pour vous citer un exemple par
exemple il me simon m'a raconté cette
histoire
un paysan elle n'avait pas suffisamment
de place dans sa bétaillère et bien il a
attaché la vache derrière son camion la
vache était tenu par une corde est
évident que le camion allait trop vite
pour elle il a elle tombait tout et tout
les 3 m et aller dans ces conditions
atroces et ceux ci enfin on pourra citer
comme ça des dizaines et des dizaines de
crève les yeux des vaches on fait des
choses fonctionnent en a profité pour ça
que ce décret bien ils ont terminé sur
note un tout petit peu plus souriante
même françoise dorin créé au théâtre en
toile une nouvelle comédie un sale
égoïste maurice et qui est un sale
égoïste et qui essayent de défendre sa
liberté son indépendance qu'il a
chèrement acquise il est entouré par
béatrice pretty claude gensac marion
gamme
michel roux qui assurait aussi la mise
en scène pour le verset jacques mareuil
mais entre victor pouvez vous
m'expliquer pourquoi madame bonneville
qui n'a aucun don ni aucun goût pour la
culture a tenu absolument à se charger
de la fabrication de ses rideaux mais
pour rendre service à monsieur primo ça
ne me rend pas service seconde où j'ai
horreur des dettes de reconnaissance les
deux d'argent encore une fois qu'on les
arrêts clés se finit on n'en parle plus
mais les dettes de reconnaissance à
n'est jamais fini parce que la
reconnaissance à ne se mesure pas on
peut pas dire à son créancier je vous
dois encore de sourire 3 compliments et
une amabilité après autres actifs on est
débiteur avis et c'est une position qui
met particulièrement
désagréable je l' ai déjà expliqué cent
fois madame bonneville alors pourquoi
n'en tient elle pas content parce que
les deux salles triste inconditionnels
qui s'obstinent à rendre service aux
gens contre leur propre volonté
comment savez-vous à la distraction pour
les écrits de deux ans un mur le nez
devant un mur parce que si je me mettais
devant une fenêtre ouverte je risquerais
effectivement d'être très discrète
le moindre bruit le moindre oisons qui
passerait c'est un prétexte pour
m'échapper pour m'évader penser à autre
chose et plus du tout à ce que j'écris
entretenu de bonnes relations avec les
auteurs dramatiques masculin aux
excellentes je ne sais pas s'ils
entretiennent de bonnes avec moi mais
moi oui sûrement
je connais d'ailleurs très peu mais mes
confrères japonais marcel achard qui
m'appelle toujours m je me demande s'il
ya quand même pas un petit peu d'ironie
de sa part quand tu fais ça tu pourrais
faire une exception pour le petit de
tourner parce que j'ai vue n'est acquis
je faire son premier rang sans plus s'il
fallait que je m'intéresse à tous les
gens à qui tu as offert un ours en
peluche quand il était petit ma vie ne
suffirait pas à pas les fabriquer et tu
en as littéralement inondé amis voisins
relation connaissance et quelquefois
même les quêteurs à qui tu ne voulais
rien donné je n'ai pas de mener les
études mais voilà un bel ours en peluche
un d'erratique pape a ramené de la
fabrique
eh bien ça leur faisait plaisir surtout
quand ils qu'était pour les vieillards
de l'arrondissement a toujours eu le
coeur c'est peut-être mais moi je ne
mets pas de foot un rendu dans le tronc
dépôts et seulement tu refuses à ta mère
le minuscule services qu'elle sera
demain et encore ta poubelle
françoise denrées ce que la ville un
auteur dramatique est compatible avec la
vie des d'épouser la vie de mère bien
sûr que c'est compatible évidemment se
présentent des difficultés mais pas plus
que pour une employée de bureau
une femme médecin ou une journaliste à
la télévision encore moi je travaille
chez moi c'est donc plus facile de faire
tenir en même temps mes devoirs de deux
femmes de mères et de la profession
c'est denise boyard qui s'entretenait
avec françoise dorin maintenant il est
l'heure de nous quitter
je vous dis pas au revoir il vous
souhaite un bon après midi